[Musique]
mais
Oh
[Musique]
nous sommes à côté d'un voyage moi et ma fille
C'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
avoir un peu de connaissances
ceux que tu trouves dans l'eau tu es
en danger ils ont annoncé un peu
savoir se défendre
[Musique]
sur 5
nous devons faire face à un gros obstacle
que ce que la rivière sauvage qui ont été
beaucoup d'avocats peut-être ici et juste comme
J'ai malheureusement dû voir des gens
connu et que
connaissance ou connaissances de parents qui
ils sont revenus dead west donne moi donne moi
la tristesse la peur tant sont à la fois la la
sentiments mitigés que l'on ressent
mais nous allons toujours pour un rêve
Eh bien, pour donner un avenir meilleur aux
famille
[Musique]